All right, here's a sneak peek into
what's on my bookshelf. Russell Brunson,
[music]
love all of his stuff. I've got a a lot
of philosophy
that I love to read, old stoic stuff.
Ben Settle has his own section, [music]
that's for sure. I definitely enjoy a
ton of Ben Settle. In fact, I have so
many of his letters. A big fiction
section, Dungeon Crawler Carl is one of
the best voice writing books ever. Demon
Copperhead, really really good book. So,
those are really good. Anything by
Robert Greene [music] is a big win. I
have another fiction section here. All
the Red Rising stuff,
>> [music]
>> Way of Kings, anything Brandon Sanderson
has written is really good. Strength of
the Few is okay, the first book was much
better.
And my copywriting section, so tons of
stuff on writing.
Dan Kennedy, Jim Edwards, Ben Settle,
tons of Ben Settle over there. Ogilvy,
Joe Sugarman, Eddie Shlainer, Matthew
Diggs, Cashvertising, Drew Whitman,
David Garfinkel, [music] tons of guys in
here.
Brian Kurtz, got a ton of that kind of
stuff. Older classic fiction, I love
older classic [music] fiction like War
and Peace and the Brothers Karamazov,
Lord of the Rings.
Some self-help stuff right down here.
I put it at the bottom because I haven't
touched this in years. Mostly just read
copywriting and fiction. Ooh, all of the
Red Rising stuff, Power Broker,
Mistborn,
>> [music]
>> really really good. More self-help stuff
that I read many many years ago. Still
good stuff, just don't really touch it
very much nowadays. Derek Sivers, highly
underestimated. And then over here, more
creativity, thinking, productivity,
business. And Ryan Holiday has a big
section. I enjoy his stuff. Seth Godin,
the Ikigai stuff. Really really cool.
So, that is [music]
a big picture look into my 600 book
personal library. I'm close to 1,000,
>> [music]
>> and 1,000 is a legitimate library. So,
I'm excited.